dozen women who say Jeffrey Epstein
abused them have told their stories to a
judge
while newly revealed police video takes
us inside fc's Florida mansion the video
comes from a 2005 investigation of
Epstein's relationships with underage
girls Epstein was jailed in New York
City on sex trafficking charges earlier
this year he took his own life more than
two weeks ago molla Langley is covering
the Epstein case molla what does this
video show oh good morning the footage
shows what appears to be the ground
floor of Jeffrey Epstein's home the
upstairs as well as the pool area
Epstein's Palm Beach house is just one
of the locations where many of his
alleged victims say they were abused the
video was also appears to show one of
EPs teens most high-profile alleged
accomplices the 2005 video shows armed
police enter Jeffrey Epstein's Palm
Beach homes according to CBS West Palm
Beach affiliate wpe see police are seen
reading a search warrant to Epstein's
house manager upstairs there's a photo
of what appears to be Epstein's
ex-girlfriend d'Alene Maxwell she's been
accused of recruiting underage girls for
Epstein Maxwell has not been charged and
denies any wrongdoing there's also a
photo of what appears to be a gray
haired man and a brunette woman in the
White House press briefing room CBS News
is unable to authenticate the photo our
affiliate reports there are also nude
photos of women throughout the house
three years after this video has taken
Epstein was convicted of child
prostitution and served 13 months in
jail according to the New York City
Medical Examiner's Office
Epstein hanged himself earlier this
month while facing new criminal charges
a federal judge is now expected to
dismiss the criminal case against the
disgraced financier pretty upsetting to
see how many lives he's devastated
Epstein accuser Shante Davies is one of
23 alleged victims the court heard from
during a hearing in New York Tuesday
makes me sick to my stomach that there's
perpetrators out there that obviously
helped him in many ways
for a very long time and they're still
out there with no punishment in court
Davies and other accusers took aim at
Epstein's alleged accomplices Davies
claims she was introduced to Epstein by
ghilane Maxwell accuser of Virginia
Roberts qu Frey also said she was
recruited by Maxwell and that the
reckoning must not end attorney Gloria
Allred represents multiple epstein
accusers Jeffrey Epstein death whether
it was a suicide or murder
does not end the case does not end their
fight for justice
Epstein's attorneys say they also want
answers after questioning the medical
examiners finding that Epstein died by
hanging himself the lawyers say the
report is inadequate they believe the
broken bones and Epstein's neck are more
consistent with assault and homicide
Adrianna mola thank you